maintenant quand il ya des discussions
sur les sanctions contre la fédération
de russie je ne peux pas entendre de
doute je ne peux pas avoir d' indécision
après tout ce que nous avons vécu en
ukraine c'est le président de l'ukraine
mais nous ne savons pas ce qu'ils
utilisent nous ne savons pas ce qu'il
boit ne savons pas ce qu'ils fument nous
sommes donc favorables à un nouveau
train de sanctions encore plus lourde
est insupportable pour le pouvoir russe
nous sommes prêts à des mesures
drastiques sur les importations de
charbon et de pétrole russe donc il est
indispensable nos approvisionnements
énergétiques qui correspondent à des
intérêts vitaux pour nos populations des
industries ne constituent pas des
leviers politiques aux mains de pays
succédé dans jouer dans le cadre de
stratégies agressives contre nous contre
eux nos partenaires deuxièmement quand
nous allons imposer une interdiction des
transactions bancaires lâchait trop
grandes banques 8 parmi elles vcb la
deuxième plus grande du pays nous sommes
dans une situation de puissance totale
nous nous agitons est en fait nous
faisons le jeu hélas de poutine
nous devons être plus prudents dans nos
livraisons alimentaires à l'étranger et
surveiller en particulier les conditions
de ses exportations vers les pays qui
mènent contre nous une politique hostile
c'est pas françois réagit il dénonce une
cruauté toujours plus horribles qui
frappe en ukraine et vous voyez sur
cette image le souverain pontife qui a
déployé un drapeau ukrainien venant de
boudhha les vidéos et les photographies
qui vous sont présentées de façon
orientés sont le résultat d'un spectacle
bien orchestré
c'est un show une mise en scène tragique
soudain dans la gare
une voix s'élève
celle d'une célébrité ukrainienne le
chanteur d'un groupe très populaire dans
le pays la presse écrite continue à très
beau minable
et de minables vous dites ah oui dans la
presse ce qui est en dessous de tout le
parisien le monde virtuel mars c'est
tragique plus aucune pizza buitoni ne
sort de cette usine du nord de la france
sur ordre du préfet par un arrêté pris
le 1er avril rendu public seulement
aujourd'hui il dit constater un niveau
des grades et de la maîtrise de
l'hygiène alimentaire en france des
centaines de fromage rappeler des rayons
ils sont susceptibles de contenir des
bactéries responsables de la listériose
une infection alimentaire qui peut être
meurtrières avec toutes ces bactéries
qui se développent
on n'a pas eu assez de scandales entre
le lait contaminé lactalis il y a
quelques années où déjà il y avait une
commission d' enquête parlementaire qui
avait dit qu a besoin
d'investir 800 postes à la direction
générale de l'alimentation pour faire
des contrôles plus conséquent jean luc
mélenchon en meeting
et puis soudain au regard des fonds non
logram qui apparaît dans onze autres
villes je sens c'est vrai un espoir se
lever dans le pays de dun changement qui
je crois est attendu mais encore une
fois je ne m'avancerai pas sur les
résultats du premier tour tout
simplement pour une bonne raison c'est
que je serai au second tour et que donc
le le 25 au matin je serai soit
président de la république soit chef de
l'opposition un emmanuel macron qui
parti tellement à droite que ce n'est
plus du tout une option pour les gens de
gauche même de gauche modérée quand on
voit son bilan et son programme
notamment sur les retraites ce n'est
plus une option et quand on voit de
l'autre côté jean luc mélenchon la seule
erreur que j'ai commise c'est quand j'ai
cru les services français et les
autorités françaises et monsieur zemsky
plutôt que les américains alors
maintenant je m'en souviendrai pour le
futur quand les américains disent ya un
risque d'agression et bien c'est pas les
français qu'il faut écouter chez les
américains je ne les renvoie pas doses
at home et ce sont d'un côté une impasse
conte mêlant chants de l'autre côté ça
n'est plus une option pour la gauche